By Hollywood standards, Robert Pattinson has
been around for what seems like a lifetime
already.
It's been 14 years since Pattinson made his
big-screen debut in Harry Potter and the Goblet
of Fire, and not even a decade has passed
since he stole the hearts of tweens the world
over as the Twilight saga's brooding vampire
Edward Cullen.
Since then, Pattinson has carved out one of
the most intriguing careers in Hollywood by
continuing to claim challenging and quirky
roles in independent films.
When it was announced that Pattinson was returning
to big franchise movies by claiming the coveted
lead in Warner Bros.' superhero flick The
Batman, the internet nearly imploded at the
prospect of Pattinson donning the cape to
play the Dark Knight.
While there were some positive reactions,
many fans were quite displeased at the casting
news.
"Take it.
They'll hate you for it, but that's the point
of Batman.
He can be the outcast."
It turns out that die-hard Bat-fans weren't
the only ones miffed when that news broke.
In a recent interview with Variety, Pattinson
said he was also pretty upset about the news,
but for a totally different reason.
He said:
"When that thing leaked, I was f---ing furious.
Everyone was so upset.
Everyone was panicking from my team.
I sort of thought that had blown up the whole
thing."
It seems that when Variety initially broke
the casting exclusive, the deal to bring Pattinson
to Gotham was far from done.
In fact, the actor hadn't yet officially auditioned
for the role, and talks with Warner Bros.
and The Batman director Matt Reeves were very
much still ongoing.
The reason Pattinson was so upset was because
he really wanted the part, and was afraid
all the premature chatter from internet fandom
might actually scare Warner Bros. away from
casting him.
On the day the Batman news broke, Pattinson
found himself compulsively Googling his own
name for news about the expected fallout.
Luckily, Warner Bros. eventually stood up
for its casting decision regarding The Batman,
confirming Pattinson would indeed portray
the Caped Crusader in Reeves' upcoming film.
Ironically, even after flipping out about
someone else leaking his involvement with
The Batman before it was a done deal, Pattinson
himself accidentally let a spoiler slip for
another hotly anticipated Warner Bros. movie:
Todd Phillips' Joker.
During his chat with Variety, Pattinson was
said to have made a "mundane comment" about
Joker star Joaquin Phoenix before "asking
to retract it," as it apparently spoiled something
in the film, even if it was relatively minor.
The actor admitted that he's not used to thinking
about spoilers during interviews.
He said:
"Oh s---.
I definitely should not say that.
I'm so used to pretty art-house movies, where
you can watch the movie three times and still
not know what it's about."
Pattinson might just be an inspired casting
choice who could be more than capable of bringing
pathos and physicality to one of the most
complicated superheroes ever created.
If you don't believe that, look past Pattinson's
Twilight years and seek out some of the indie
gems he's been cranking out of late, particularly
the sci-fi flick High Life.
Reeves and company have yet to announce any
more casting for The Batman, which has not
yet begun filming.
It's slated to hit theaters in June 2021,
so we've got a bit of a wait ahead to see
what Pattinson brings to the complex dual
roles of Bruce Wayne and Batman.
Here's hoping he delivers the goods when The
Batman finally swings into action in a couple
of years.
But fear not, Team Pattinson.
The actor's chiseled features will be more
than visible on big screens in the intervening
years, with Robert Eggers' The Lighthouse
on the immediate horizon and David Michôd's
The King hitting Netflix soon after.
Pattinson is also hard at work shooting Christopher
Nolan's Tenet this very moment, with that
film scheduled to hit theaters next year.
"I'm quite glad I'm doing a Chris movie, because
I've got something else to be nervous about."
2020 will also see Pattinson appear in the
anxiously awaited adaptation of Donald Ray
Pollock's beloved novel The Devil All The
Time.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.